president Trump and North Korean leader
Kim jong-un did not make a deal at their
second summit after the talks ended
overnight mr. Trump said quote sometimes
you have to walk the president said Kim
wanted sanctions fully lifted in
exchange for closing only some of its
nuclear sites the two leaders left
Vietnam that plans for a third meeting
last June they did sign commitments
during their first historic summit army
general Vincent Brooks helped coordinate
that meeting in Singapore he was
commander of US forces in Korea from
2016 until late last year he retired on
January 1st and he's with us now general
Brooks welcome good morning good to have
you here general
let me ask you this the the North Korean
leader got to walk on the world stage in
essential parity with the American
president the u.s. position on
verification appears to have changed the
president had said he was a good person
they have a good friendship what did the
u.s. get well what I was happy to see
was that there's progress in creating a
new relationship between North and South
Korea and between the United States and
North Korea and this progress was upset
by yesterday's outcome there was a
chance to move much further in
establishing a new relationship like a
declaration of into war and that didn't
happen and so what the u.s. got out of
this is a clearer understanding of what
it is the concerns kim giman the most
and that he does indeed intend to
release his nuclear weapons but he
doesn't know the way to get there and
doesn't have a foundation of trust was
it a diplomatic failure and who was a
winner and a loser here if there is how
you think well I certainly wouldn't call
it a diplomatic failure it's another
step in diplomacy and first I'm very
happy as a military former commander to
see that there is diplomacy and that
there's not need to pursue a military
option at the present time and that's
what we were pursuing in 2017 but who's
the winner in all this really no one no
one walked away with what they wanted
South Korea didn't see the progress they
hoped for China didn't see the progress
they hoped for North Korea didn't get
the relief they wanted the United States
did not get the disclosure wanted I
still don't call that a failure though I
think this is a clear end of Kate in
dication of where we are and how many
more steps there have to be remember
this is a country that doesn't know
anything about trust put that back for
Kim though I would say it's a big
setback for Kim on the international
stage he has lost face
and now they'll have to do something to
respond well Walden North Koreans have
said that they will not continue
ballistic missile testing doesn't this
though give them more time to continue
and incentive to keep building their
nuclear weapons without having to
disclose them it gives them more time
under sanctions and so that's what Kim
Zealand has made very clear he would
like to see relieved it's 450 days since
the last provocation and yes I'm
counting I wasn't and I still am and
that's important to recognize he said he
was going in a different direction and
he indeed has go in a different
direction but Kim jong-un does not know
the way forward on building trust he
also said in his New Year's message that
if sanctions were not lifted he would be
forced to take a quote/unquote new path
are we closer or further away coming out
of this meeting to this new path I think
we're closer now this is this is strange
all right this has been my experience
with Korea over many many years many
decades often you're closer when you
feel like you were further apart it
sounds geological but it's absolutely
true so kim giman now has a better
understanding of what he didn't get and
what he really wants which is economic
development
it's nothing once his nuclear weapons he
wants economic development and he now
sees that he has to take a different way
to get there he gambled and missed the
general we've seen the North Koreans
play footsie when sanctions start to
bite they come there were talks before
about nuclear disarmament they broke
down over verification so haven't we
seen this play before and why then would
this time be different it's there are
some similarities but I think what's
important to note is what it's different
this time
first kim giman is different he's not
his father he's not his grandfather and
he's trying to deliver something that he
believed they attempted and failed to do
a new relationship of the United States
peace on the Korean Peninsula
preservation of the regime and economic
growth and development that he delivers
and so this is a different circumstance
than before what he also achieved the
nuclear weapons that is his grandfather
did not mean we have 28 thousand troops
in South Korea which you commanded as
well as their families do you believe
they are safer because of this new
relationship between the South Korean
president north can president and what
Trump is doing oh I absolutely do and as
you saw when you were there back in 2017
the environment importantly builds
around the sense of whether a in
immediate danger is emerging or not and
of course there's the danger of
artillery the weapon systems are still
there but the intention has changed and
a threat really is combined of those two
things capability and intention and I
would say the intention is very low
right now to engage in dangerous
activities but there's not the progress
that we're looking for and as a result
some of the danger still remains you
anticipate a third meeting I do I do I
think there will be a third meeting but
there will also be another South Korea
and North Korea meeting and probably
another China North Korea meeting and
they will express their concerns to kim
giman and maybe help to try to put him
back on track as well have you involved
in that
[Laughter]
well I am I can't be completely
disappointed by this North Korea is a
country that doesn't understand trusts
it doesn't have trust internally and it
doesn't have trust experienced
externally and so we shouldn't be
surprised that the trip dear White House
will be calling you later today talking
talking is always better than fire
exactly general Vincent Brooks thank you
thank you all right thank you